[Music]
any shoe you need i probably have
if i don't have it i can get it for you
in 24 hours
if you're a rapper you have a video
shoot you need the shoes coming out in
two weeks
i just have to make a call and i'll get
it for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tune into
dj khaled snapchat the key to more
success is to have a lot of pillows
one of my favorite dj called appearances
is this kid ben how's business in the
new year booming
i see you he's 16 years old and he's at
the helm of a burgeoning sneaker empire
one that he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like dj khaled and chris brown
are you at the studio meet the sneaker
don
so my name is benjamin kapolishenik
people call me benjamin cakes but most
you guys know me as a sneaker dog
[Music]
school ends at three o'clock i get home
at like four eat dinner do some homework
and go straight to the office space and
like any good don family is important
i'm ben's little's brother i'm his
manager so if you need anything call me
okay not that family i'm the mother of
the sneaker don
to me he's my little boy but i also see
a businessman he had a goal he's
self-driven he's motivated he's a hard
worker
the great dons they say come from humble
beginnings
the first pair of sneakers actually got
me in sneak game i was in fifth grade
the galaxy pack came out and i got the
lebrons i love sneakers after that
probably around sixth grade when my
parents didn't want to fund my sneaker
hub anymore i had to figure out a way
how to get the money for it and then i
realized if i buy
five or ten pairs by paying people to
stand in line for me i could sell it to
a larger clientele and make more money
plus get my shoe for free
and then
it just finally broke through and money
started coming in
at first it amazed me how sneakers can
go for like so much money for like one
shoe people charging a thousand i
thought it was like a joke or something
a thousand dollars
but hey that's why he's the sneaker don
[Music]
so what comes next
i'm really excited to open up a physical
store the first location's going to be
miami and then i'm trying to do la new
york and chicago
all my friends when they dropped out of
sneak game they're like it's dead it's
over
there's no more like you're not getting
anything you're wasting your time you're
going to lose money
none of that what was true
play themselves
[Music]
once upon a time on the island of sicily
there was a race that ran right through
your village
[Music]
it was glorious it was beautiful it was
clearly planned before safety was a
consideration
[Music]
the targer florio was founded in sicily
by a speed loving fellow named vincenzio
florio in 1906 and it enthralled the
racing world for decades to come
but this was no ordinary race it took
place in the mountains outside of
palermo racers encountered bandits
wolves 500-plus hairpin turns on roads
that hadn't changed since togas were in
fashion
the course went straight through towns
and villages with no barricades or
warnings
the first year a driver named alessandro
cagno won it took him nine hours and his
average speed was 30 miles an hour
the targa florio ran for 71 years titans
of the car world like mario andretti
competed but a growing realization that
the race was crazy dangerous led to it
being shut down in 1977
it was the longest running car race in
the world at the time today the
grandstand outside palermo sits empty
but evidence of the race is everywhere
peaking out in the beautiful landscape
the targa florio became synonymous with
a long and grueling race in the years
after its end tribute targets have
popped up across the world but true
racing enthusiasts know
it all began here
[Music]
[Music]
when my little brother lucas was born my
parents were told that he wouldn't walk
or talk and the doctors even said he
might not make it to his 10th birthday
but today a few months away from his
10th birthday we're doing our 15th
triathlon together
my name is noah aldrich and this is my
brother lucas aldrich
lucas
you guys i'm talking
[Music]
noah is 11 and lucas is nine and lucas
was born with a rare genetic neurologic
condition called lysencephaly
he's unable to walk unable to talk he's
unable to feed himself but despite all
of his challenges he's the happiest
little boy that you'll ever meet
about four years ago our boys started
doing triathlons together and most cases
that wouldn't be a big deal a lot of
kids do triathlons but there's something
very special about the way our boys do
triathlons
[Music]
i pull lucas in a raft for the swim
portion
then i pull him in a bike cart during
the bike
and i push him in a running cart during
the run
i wanted to do this because lucas can't
do things like we can he can't really
play sports so this is something we
could do together
currently we're training for our 15th
triathlon which is this weekend
before the race i always feel nervous i
don't think i'll ever get over that i
just don't want to hurt lucas i don't
care if i win the race he just has to be
okay
[Music]
before the race lucas gets serious and
he gets his race face on and they're
ready to compete
[Music]
they swim around 200 yards
then they transition to a bike
they'll go usually about three to five
miles
and then they'll run about a mile
noah is strong physically and especially
mentally because he's truly only doing
these races for his brother
sometimes i feel like that it's gotta be
over soon right but i just hear lucas
that's how he says go faster
every day is precious with that little
boy
i try to soak in the experience because
we don't know how long the boys will be
able to do triathlons together any one
of them could be their last
what these boys accomplish gives me a
nice sense of pride
noah and lucas are an inspiration people
see these two young boys and it gives
them hope and it gives them
encouragement to go out and tackle life
challenges
[Music]
this is my friend laura and she's 80
years old and this is my friend tiffany
and she is
26.
and we live in a retirement community
[Music]
i'm a part of the artisan residence
program at judson manor which is a
residential program where young
musicians get to live here rent free in
exchange for performing recitals and
concerts
when i tell people i live in the
retirement community i get a lot of
mixed reactions some people
don't believe me
other people
think it's a wonderful idea
i had not been a part of this community
more than
two days
i was in the lobby and they told me
about tiffany and i walked over and
introduced myself and i said do you like
dogs
oh she loves dogs
and tiffany and i became friends we just
formed a
friendship we'll talk about art we talk
about clothes
i don't wear shoe fashionable shoes
anymore but tiffany does and we talk
about shoes
laura to me is like a grandma
and also a friend and a confidant
i don't think the age difference is
something that i am constantly thinking
about or that i'm aware of you don't
think oh i'm having dinner with this 100
year old and this 90 year old you know
i'm having dinner with my friend laura
and sarah
in a way it is almost like being in a
college dorm with the fact that there
are so many people here
from different places from different
backgrounds it might be a little bit
quieter
than a normal college dorm
but i think we still have just as much
fun
[Music]
you